ah I was the only one who tucked there
was again no reason for that I still
don't really understand what tucking is
you shove your balls up into your body
and welcome to our special two-year
anniversary video for the past two years
we've been making videos together and
becoming close friends so today we're
gonna re-watch several of our very first
videos
oh my see what shaped us into becoming
who we are today where are my pants do
don't get it
don't get it the first video that I
chose we should watch is actually our
Kim Kardashian butt photo video does
this make me look more like a sexy
librarian I edited this footage and I
can say glimpses of everyone's dick were
put into BuzzFeed's
permanent backup systems it's not
started a trend of Eugene way out
dressing us in every shoot and drinking
in every shoe not a trend that's how I
dress the office for the first couple
videos we tried really hard to get other
people involved we're basically the dry
guys because we're the grossest people
at BuzzFeed oh yeah I think what's
interesting though is that the four of
us are not necessarily traditional like
super hyper masculine confident dudes
and to have to put our butts on the
internet I was a huge stuff for all of
us once you go but you can't go back my
favorite G moment by far is an arcade
drama episode when Eugene just like
brutally attacked Ned with his mouth i
won haha what did you win seducing you
[Music]
what's next this is one of my all-time
favorites the try guys try drag for the
first time it was kind of like our first
time really immersing ourselves into
another culture ah not only transforming
physically but having to perform and act
out something over a course of a day
inside of your body it's like if you'd
run with a cold pool and your balls kind
of retreat I just don't maybe my balls
are tube there's cavities there that's
where they descended from because of
this video if we ever encounter drag
queens they know us by our drag persona
and gingivitis my name is ginger vados
I'm so sweet I'm gonna give you a comedy
but don't worry I thought this was the
day before Thanksgiving and all during
Thanksgiving dinner my grandma just
asked me relentlessly about drag culture
I'm like grandma I did this for one day
but what do you want to know Ned looked
like every trashy Hollywood starlet that
was close to crashing and burning I
think I would go to the bar I would try
and pick up Eugene and I'd end up going
home with Ned Hale yeah I'm going after
Ned and I would let everyone
gosh there's so many dumb dead moments
yes obviously like any fan could make a
30-minute montage of any time Ned has
mentioned my wife my wife my wife my
wife my wife my wife I can't wait to
have Oh gross daddy likey I love this
next video so much it's called the try
guys test the legal alcohol limit and
it's the first time that we applied
scientific principles to something you
don't normally get to scientific about
aka
partying rankings ranked and it's the
morning after I feel like [ __ ] death
it's really funny seeing the people that
we were able to convince to come to my
house to get drunk on a I was very
intimidated dancing with this girl yeah
she was a very good dancer and she
wasn't my wife I don't know what to do
with my hands okay honestly key tonight
we were being very responsible during
this video Zack and Ned became little
kids yeah what better way to have fun
than by hitting all your friends not
even legally responsible I think it's
awesome that we get to educate people as
well as entertainment and we've
continued that trend with videos like
try guys get prostate exams try guys
test their sperm count bottom I will try
to make science cool did it to me this
is proved proven people get drunk
my favorite keep moment is probably the
time when he made me almost pee myself
from laughing so hard try guys try
edible lingerie oh where he's got his
lingerie stuck in his mouth
oh they're like stuck to my teeth oh god
they're turning my hands red I'm gonna
get Kanye now that we got pizza what's
next so this is the try guys try UFC
fighting our next restore for
straight-up like two weeks after this
let's watch Eugene get tossed look at
that big boner I had that was not a
boner with a cuff everyone thinks the
gene has a boner in the game is video
it's a cop that were you actually afraid
of getting hit yes also he showed the
example of how to do the Achilles hold
so many times that he bruised my
Achilles
I love athletic competitions hmm any
time we do a competition video these two
immediately forget that we're filming a
video and it becomes all about beating
each other but that also makes for a
great video
me and Zach don't fight we just hug I do
not endorse this at all he'll look did
eugene beat me in this fight technically
sure yes I didn't want to hurt you hurt
you you say that you punch him in the
back of the head I would be honest I
didn't have a hernia before the try guys
it's really surprising that I haven't
gotten injured in a try guys for you
well you're already so injured before we
shoot the try because there's no point
in getting more imitating mr. Cass yeah
[Music]
so my favorite Zakk moment is when he
innocently discovers his face is the
clitoris where's the clitoris my tea
is my face the clitoris oh my god I'm
the clitoris there's a world of people
who know me exclusively at the clip guy
and it's for nothing else
Thank You world I've made my mark what a
toasty vagina Eugene is that whiskey
what are you what are you where did that
come from
and that's have you've been it's 11:00
a.m. have you been sitting on that this
whole time
cheers Cheers two years oh wait if we're
if we're toasting then pour me some
whiskey Jesus
you know we're drinking whiskey that
makes me think of pregnancy that's
another good series so this is the video
where we let people electrocute our
bellies this legitimately terrified me
well this isn't a skill this is just
pain the faces that Keith makes is you
have such a mouth flexibility keith has
the largest mouth I've ever seen on a
human it could swallow world's let's all
make a Keith face oh so much of this
video is screaming watching your friends
get hurt is so delightful like this was
just muscle contractions but like a baby
can rip you apart what we're trying to
say is men are giant [ __ ] us
especially so yeah oh yeah you got pizza
I think we should watch the first video
we ever made like it's been two years
September 12 of 20,000 14 2014 yeah
that's where it all began what I
remember about this is that we were
worried about people seeing us in
underwear oh how far we've come oh okay
I remember that there underwear is so
much cozier than our underwear is it's
so cozy this is also when we weren't
known by first-name basis the audience
so I was always the Asian one tall guy
with glasses short guy with class tiny
nerd
nobody knows just a white guy it's funny
I don't love this video but I'm so
appreciative for it because it kind of
started us on this journey right like I
look at the last two years how much I've
grown as a person how much we've grown
as friends and how much I've grown as a
video maker and this is really where it
all started I think as someone who's
never had brothers this is the closest
I've had to have a brother it's been two
years we've swam with sharks we fought
each other we've been naked for an
entire day in the hot Sun we voted into
the ocean well you've owned well one of
us okay we did it together the only
reason that's possible is because people
keep watching it so thanks thank you
it's really because of the audience
right it's only what it is but here's
the money shot
[Music]
promise you if we get to 200 episodes oh
so you want that's the second most
requested video do you guys ever stop
and think about how many millions of
people have seen your butt
[Music]